Here's everything I eat in a day six months postpartum.
I obviously have to start off with a hot cup of tea
and some protein powder. For breakfast,
I was craving something sweet,
so I made a German pancake for the first time.
I don't know why these are called German pancakes
because being from Germany,
I've never seen them before,
but I'm just gonna roll with it.
Pop that in the oven for about 35 minutes.
Once it was done, I cut myself a piece,
popped it with some homemade apron jam and some fresh mixed berries,
and this hit the spot. It was so good,
but I still prefer the original German pancake,
the little pick me up. I had a vanilla blueberry iced tea,
then got started on making a baked salad.
I wanted something fresh but still comforting
since it is getting a little colder.
I made some lemon pepper asparagus and kale,
za atar chickpeas and maple harissa carrots.
Pop that in the oven, fried up some prosciutto
and in the same pan also sauteed some shallots and chili,
and then it was time to plate.
I topped everything with a miso lemon vinaigrette,
gave that a good toss, and lunch was served.
Is one of my favorite fall meals,
and it comes together really quick.
All I was craving today was comforting meals.
So for dinner I made some lasagna soup,
made some mozzarella cheese,
moved on to making my pasta dough,
and while That was resting.
I diced up some celery, onion,
and carrot. Once my sauce came together,
I rolled out my pasta, cut it into regular shapes,
and let that finish cooking in my sauce.
Once that was done, I tossed in the mozzarella we made.
At this point, I was starving and so hungry,
so I plated it up, topped it with some Parmesan cheese
and some spring onion. Even though I burned my mouth,
this was so good. I always need something sweet,
so I made some vanilla ice cream.
Lucky made some cookies. After taking my magnesium, it was time for bed.